people of the internet's retro Records
who are here and guys we have to talk
about the most overpowered ridiculous
spell right now in Harry Potter magic
awaken at least on the PVP side of
things and I think it's actually whiz
bang man so once you hit Grand Master
and I think it's 8100 once you get past
that there are no bands anymore so you
look here I'm starting off I'm running
low but there are no bands and in
addition to there being no bands you can
also ban the other person's deck
so you can ban certain Echoes so
Bellatrix you guys know Bellatrix is my
main a Bellatrix is getting banned
against me a lot if you ever run into me
you definitely want to ban Bellatrix
trust me but I'm working on my Hermione
and in this video I want to show you the
sheer power
of Hermione and whizbang okay so look at
this I'm down 33-24 to 1752.
that is just a huge huge difference
right there and right now I'm kind of
just waiting I'm letting my mp build get
hit by the orb of water use the
broomstick to escape a little bit of it
okay so now 33 19 to 14 29 there we go
Hermione throwing the double
thunderstorm now I also look at that I
have a whiz-bang ready to go for only
two MP which is crazy hit him with the
inflators hit him with the whizbang so
they're at 22.94 before and all the way
down to 17 33 after but we're not done
yet we're not done so Hermione and the
lightning and the whiz-bang they helped
me catch up a little bit
but I am still down in this fight and
you can see they're about halfway to
another Death Eater I wait for the
nebulous to wear off we throw another
thunderstorm
then I always like to kind of go inside
the nebulous when I'm getting ready to
throw a thunderstorm or get ready for
the whiz-bang combo now a lot of people
using carceros
with whiz bang and I do think it works a
little bit better however inflatus for
me has just a little bit more utility
although recently I've been trying to
experiment with incarcers as well so we
got two Death Eaters on the field but
now things are much more even and I'm
not sure why they walked into it right
there and now I'm ready to go I'm ready
to go watch this watch this inflatus
whizbank
I still
I still actually almost lost that Death
Eater in the top left nearly got me okay
so in the last one you got to see a
little bit of a comeback in this one
you're gonna get to see an even Warren
saying come back so here you can see the
little screen what it looks like when
you get to ban the other person's Echo
so as you can see Bellatrix gets banned
so I go with my Hermione again which I
don't even have a Hermione legendary
that's good enough yet to run in PvP so
I need to work on getting one of those
Echoes but this fight I'm gonna be
honest with you guys don't watch this
fight right here for tips on Hermione
watch this fight for tips on how
insanely overpowered whiz-bang is so
we've got a little bit of a discrepancy
right there 3464 to 30 70 for me and the
thing about Hermione at the start of a
fight you have to use your lower MP cost
cards just to lower the cost of the big
ones so we're going against the Snape
Echo here which the Snape Echoes man
I've ran into some really tough snake
players and so you can see I'm trying to
serve my big damage spells we did get
Hermione out and got to use the
thunderstorm
which in turn helped us take care of the
locomotors
they did use a Time Turner now we're
both kind of just waiting letting MP
build so really I won that first
exchange though because remember they
started out with a little bit more
Health but now things are about to go
completely the opposite way I'm about to
get absolutely destroyed right here
I'm not sure why I'm not throwing
thunderstorms
why
yeah that was that was a misplay I'm not
sure what I was like okay finally I
throw I throw the thunderstorm then they
get another
another time Turner out and if you're
running up against the Snape Echo
they're almost always going to be using
Time Turner they should be anyway
because of that sectum sempra so we've
got it ready I've got a whiz-bang for
2mp
there we go inflatus and then I I
mis-timed it
I mistimed it
and it should have cost me to fight
it should have cost me the fight
but look at this I'm still I'm still
kind of setting up for it I get hit with
Ron we get hit with the locomotors we're
able to weather that a little bit you
know we're not down terribly bad right
now using atmospheric charm using
Cassandra using the things that I have
so then we hit him right there with
inflatus and whisbank but still
we didn't even hit him for
him for the exact timing of it a lot of
people will actually throw whiz bang
first okay watch this fight right here
or watch this turning point in the fight
so right now I'm kind of just buying
time all I have is inflatus I don't want
to waste it that right there being able
to avoid that accio was huge was huge
lets me heal just a little bit and I'm
just gonna be quiet right here I just
want you guys to see this
everyone we're in the beginning
look at their help look at their help
just gone just gone and here's the thing
at the time of that video I didn't even
have whizbang at level nine it was
actually level eight at the time very
fortunate on this Hermione Echo to get
plus two on thunderstorm just absolutely
incredible even though it's not a
legendary Echo so then here's the rest
of the deck it doesn't fully match what
I was using in the video I've made some
slight modifications to it and you can
see that I am trying to incorporate
incarcers as well where incarcers can
help is it casts a little bit wider of a
net and you can pull in a larger group
of enemies than you can with inflatus
and I feel like it lasts just a little
bit longer you saw that one clip where
inflatus it actually wears off and
they're able to get out of it before I
can even fully hit them with whizbang
now that could just be a timing thing as
well now if you didn't know this you can
double click anytime on a spell to
instantly cast it I have yet to do this
a lot with whizbang because
I'm just afraid that it's not going to
go to the Target that I wanted to go to
you know if there's a locomotor on the
field what if it goes to that what if it
goes to a pixie instead of actually
targeting the person so I guess if they
had nothing else on the field then you
might as well just go double click
double click so if you had like
incarcers ready they're the only one on
the field double click it and then
double click on whiz-bang and you can
just instantly hit them so with the
Hermione decks you really want to
balance a lot of low MP cost cards so
that's when we have like a pug no
nebulous as I mentioned I like to hide
in that recover a bit of Health it's
also great to try and avoid thunderstorm
you also have broomstick here which you
can use in conjunction with a Pug no and
then we have inflatus here incarceros
atmospheric charm once I've hit Grand
Master past 8100 I'm starting to run
into more and more people running the
Norwegian Ridgeback and you can deal
with the ridgeback without having
atmospheric charm but it is really
really difficult to do so atmospheric
charm just makes it so much easier to to
be able to deal with those whenever
somebody tries to hatch one and then of
course thunderstorm which is just almost
an automatic right now the way the meta
is it's almost an automatic with the
Hermione deck as well as having a
Hermione companion because it's just
free damage basically as long as you
have something to force them out of the
nebulous you can almost always get good
damage now a smart player if they have a
lot of summons that they can use they're
going to have them all out on the field
spread out I know that the fire crab is
kind of a big thing right now the fire
crabs are actually big big tanks
especially if they're kind of buried
underground so they can really tank a
lot of thunderstorm damage as well now
if you're not familiar with the
specifics on how the Hermione Echo Works
here's the breakdown for every three
spells you use so not summons it has to
be spells the MP required for the
highest cost card in your deck is halved
and then here's the one that not a lot
of people know about there is also a 45
chance that the level of the card gets a
plus one so there's a chance that your
card gets a upgraded as you're using it
just insane and you can see here a Max
4mp reduction yet that is only at one
turn so you saw how whiz-bang actually
is a cost of seven and there was a point
where we had it all the way down to two
because it had just been in our deck
kind of cycling we hadn't used it we
hadn't let it cycle I should say now my
Bellatrix deck that got me to Grand
Master is still my favorite that's the
one that I love the most if you want to
hear more about that one check out the
video over on the right side of your
screen now as always guys thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon